bon
les monsois rv est venue des gones à
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs ce soir lors l'enjeu n'est pas
avec nous puisqu'il joue le tournoi de
cannes mais nous recevons indiquent que
nous avons déjà reçu ici les
journalistes entre autres c'est bertrand
guyard et j'ai aussi bon joueur
oui enfin un peu bonjour bonjour
stéphane comment servir francs bah ça va
bien ça va bien ça se passe bien je
crois que tu as de beaucoup de projets
en cours
on en a surtout l'ensemble des trajets
alors ce soir on reçoit mais un des plus
grands joueurs français de tous les
temps mais on peut le dire je crois
pourtant que tu connais un petit peu tu
peux peut-être le présentait aussi
oui j'ai le pied c'était
c'est effectivement peut-être après
philidor donc ça remonte à loin
le
meilleur joueur d'échecs que la france
ait connu voilà donc bon soir un nouvel
outil bonsoir stephen bonsoir de francs
alors comment comment ça se passe cette
saison là écoulée qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans ton actualité que sont le
tournant que tu as joué quels sont ceux
que tu as envie de jouer et coutumes à
jouer et c'est donc le prochain tour et
que je vais faire c'est à monaco à un
tournoi qui a lieu chaque année depuis
déjà presque dix ans qui a une
particularité un moment unique au monde
c'est con c'est le seul tournoi où on
peut jouer des parties en aveugle donc
il ya le temps à diviser en deux il ya
une partie où on joue mon jeu contrôler
nos adversaires en partie rapide
normalement et ensuite on joue le même
joueur en partie l aveugle
donc bon c'est un petit peu compliqué à
expliquer mais le système c'est qu'on a
devant soi un écran d'ordinateur et cani
chic et melide il n'y a pas de pièces et
on déplace les ps à l'aide d'une souris
pour indiquer les coûts et essayent tout
et tout le reste ça se passe dans la
tête dit ça marche pas si on se trompe
de cannes alors l'ordinateur de signal
c'est pas comme on glisse où on perd la
partie tout de suite non là on est on
est même pas sanctionné simplement bon
le temps continue de s'écouler donc il
vaut mieux pas trop s'amuser quoi
d'accord et peut-être dernière jusqu'à
cette année on était allé si je me
souviens bien au tournant dans guerre et
c'est mon certains jeux remplit très
bien on a fait une émission assez longue
d'ailleurs sur ce tournoi avait gagné ce
tournoi très fort c'était en février je
crois 99
ah oui c'était en mars dernier mars
pardon est d'accord et donc c'est
peut-être le meilleur résultat de
l'année et a fait aussi championnat du
monde oui oui c'était le meilleur total
d'année c'est pas le seul tournoi que
j'ai gagné j'en avais gagné un autre
deux mois avant en allemagne en open bon
c'est moins prestigieux bien sûr quand
on a fermé mais bon ça fait plaisir
quand même et puis j'avais participé au
championnat on a pris pas mal de
péripéties parce que bon c'est que la
fille d
et pas très pas très fiable en ce moment
l'annoncent les choses
ensuite elle d'airport et c'est à vous
c'était pas du tout sûr que je joue
champion du monde finalement j'ai été
pris et bon j'ai passé deux tours ce qui
est un résultat correct donc j'ai perdu
c'étaient les seizièmes 16e de finale
contre 7 et 8ème du 8e mai contre google
phone quand on veut le faire mais je
crois que c'est un bête noire sinon
c'est ça j'ai cru comprendre ça souvent
contre lui oui oui malheureusement
c'est dommage parce que c'est la
deuxième fois que je tombe contre lui en
championnat du monde à groningen aux
cycles précédents s'était lui aussi qui
me d'éliminer et en plus bon cd match
assez serré à chaque fois on va jusqu'au
tie break mais bon il a l'air d'avoir
des nerfs plus solides que moi m'ont
vraiment pour l'instant il ya encore
encore du travail tant qu il connaît
aussi joué le bertrand mouttet tu peux
nous éclairer un peu plus sur la
personnalité de ce très grand champion
oui bah je pense qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'il a commencé à jouer jeunes c'est
que son père est un bon joueur d'échecs
qu'il a fait partie du club de kaïs avec
l'observer par paris et depuis qu'il a
été effectivement choisi il ya quand
même quelque chose d'important dans sa
carrière c'est qu'il a été je crois le
plus jeune champion du monde junior en
une suite en australie c'est ça on est
ravi et puis il a une particularité
c'est que il est l'un des rares joueurs
au monde à être positifs contre kasparov
donc quand on sait la force du bonhomme
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
quand même sur une dizaine de partis
mais à combien de joueurs comme ça que
sont positives contre kasparov
j'en connais un autre c'est boris goal
com
mais bon lui l'a vécue kasparov je crois
qu'il ya des études de trois fois en
tout il a battu deux fois avant que
kasparov ne devienne champion du monde
donc bon c'est bon disons c'est
comparable mais ça fait déjà un certain
temps qui la page 2 contre lui et à part
lui je ne pense pas comme toi tu as vu
comme une partie comme kasparov et 10 et
d'y participer en soirée 2 donc cinq et
demi à quatre et demi pour moi avec deux
victoires une défaite et sept nuls
donc ça ça mérite va une explication
sérieuse là il va falloir oui bon je
pense qu'il faut lui poser la question
aux livres tour mais bon il ya je pense
qu'il ya deux choses il ya d'une part le
fait que quand il ya un rapport comme ça
entre les joueurs quand une série est
amorcée c'est un peu difficile après
demain verser la tendance la première
fois j'ai joué en tout cas ce que j'ai
gagné une belle partie et ensuite je
pense que ça a pesé un peu dans dans la
balance
et puis elle fait aussi que quand quand
je joue contre kasparov je pense que je
suis
survolté enfin je joue mieux que
d'habitude et
bon bah quoi donc ça donne de bons
résultats avant je m'appelle une partie
en tête finir là-dessus sur se dire
quelque chose
la première partie c'est une des grandes
parties du jeu léché avec ses deux
parties où il ya eu plusieurs dames sûr
c'était bien parti où effectivement
joël a mieux joué sa queue après
kasparov a voulu prouver que c'était
qu'il était gagnant mais il y avait les
quatre dames sur l'échiquier
donc évidemment il n'en est rien la v3
j'en avais dit il en avait qu'une simple
donc
c'est le genre de partie que mon père
non mais je crois que sur tous et si je
devais donner une explication c'est que
je crois que je elle a une forte
personnalité et que c'est important à ce
niveau de jeu de montrer la kasparov que
peut-être qu'il est plus fort mais qu'il
va y avoir une vraie partie et ça que
joël c'est de montrer et moi j'ai une
théorie de ce que je pense que des
joueurs comme short et un ordre sont des
très forts grand maître et surtout
shorty et ce sont des gens qui vont
jouer des championnats contre contre
kasparov
il partait perdant donc quand on part
perdant on perd donc que joël il part
pas perdant donc alors évidemment
kasparov et certainement plus fort que
lui mais il a du mal à jouer contre lui
mais on est comme il est français c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire donc on
va on va aller un peu plus dans le futur
puisque donc tu viens ce soir donc à
l'émission et je crois donc tu es donc
c'est même certain c'est parce que je
sais donc tu es invité à ce fameux grand
prix de bordeaux du trophée celle-ci
assurance avec des trois autres joueurs
que tu connais aussi tu peux dire vous
présenter aussi les trois autres joueurs
comme tout qui tu as joué alors les
autres joueurs donc c'est adam thiam
chef et et laurent frayssinet c'est
simplement pas d'argent je le connais
très bien ça fait des années qu'on joue
les mêmes tournois je pense que la
première fois qu'on a joué l'un contre
l'autre c'était en 96 et vassas
remontoir ça fait 13 ans
bon c'est un des dix meilleurs du monde
voilà quoi il n'y a pas de problème il
est fort quatre chefs
bon là c'est un petit disons un petit
duel intéressant si jamais un joué l'un
contre l'autre
parce que il vient d'arriver en france
ça fait je crois aux besoins qui
l'installé en france et
et il est maintenant sur la liste
française est bien que bon puisse pas
vraiment considéré comme français
puisqu'il est bien arrivé néanmoins il
est occupé la première place sur la
liste française est donc bon c'est
quelque chose que j'aimerais bien changé
et le troisième jour c'est le rang
fascine et qui est qu un jeune joueur
qui est plein plein de promesses et qui
est capital ans est un mannequin fini
vice-champions du monde de calais fait
j'avais gagné le titre de championne
junior à 15 ans d'ailleurs français plus
jeune de l'histoire des ruines me sens
toujours jeune champion du monde de
toute l'histoire du jeu d'échecs voilà
un roman très très grand champion ce
soir et nous alors l'actualité cette
semaine bertrand est ce qu'on peut faire
un petit peu le tour de ce qui se passe
encore une fois ça bouge beaucoup
alors on va commencer par kasparov chez
ce grand prix oui oui mais on commence
par ça faut pas s'emballer
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur ce tournoi
c'est que c'est le premier tournoi
virtuel internationale du jeu d'échecs
alors c'est évidemment sous l'égide de
kasparov inquiète sparrow viande vient
de lancer un nouveau site qui lui est
dédié un cas sport fasse aussi de
particuliers dans les échecs c'est qui
veut être le meilleur joueur du monde
est aussi le meilleur organisateur du
vieux l'échec
et pour lancer son tournoi pour lancer
son site
il a eu l'idée de ce tournoi c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire pour le
jeu à l'échec parce que ça va permettre
effectivement peut-être de développer le
nom le
un plus grand nombre de tournois sur la
sur la terre et ça va permettre
effectivement peut-être beaucoup plus de
gens de pouvoir regarder sur les canal
web du monde entier les parties en
direct
donc j'ai alors j'aurais déjà suivi toi
ce tournoi depuis le début du mois les
résultats ou wep a pas d'autres épreuves
mais j'ai regardé un peu ce qui s'est
passé bon c'est un genre de tournoi
intéressant parce que c'est nouveau mais
non je préfère nettement les tournois
d'everett endroit où on joue on
adversaire en face de soi on peut mettre
la pression psychologique comme sa
faveur c'est bien sûr d'une part mais
pas seulement c'est parce que bon je dis
il ya quand même quelque chose autour du
jeu il n'y a pas seulement les coupons
fait il le fait que c'est intéressant de
bon d'avoir déjà un public dans la salle
qu'on puisse voir ce qui se passe
guettez éventuellement l érection d
adversaires et puis on est vraiment en
conditions de compétition là dans un
tournoi comme ça il peut y avoir des
coupures ça s'est déjà vu des problèmes
techniques
ces chaussées par des échecs sont là
dedans sont un peu ça fait plutôt
compétition démonstration que véritable
tournoi donc il manque l'aspect
effectivement aussi relation bavaisis
quand on repasse par an sur l'échiquier
d'abord c'est vrai cette comme jeu et de
mettre une pression sportive c'est vrai
qu' il ya quelque chose qu'on a pas dit
je sais pas si vous en avez parlé les
autres semaines c'est que la fennell a
le même ministère des sports a reconnu
la fédération française comme une
fédération sportive
alors c'est vrai que je l'échec ce n'est
pas un sport physique mais c'est un
sport cérébral et là c'est complètement
virtuel donc je crois que c'est je crois
que ça peut apporter des choses aux
échecs on va pas dire le contraire parce
que nous même on se sert de cette
technique de l'internet pour pouvoir
développer le jeu mais je crois que ça
ça pourra pas remplacer les compétitions
mano à mano
enfin c'est mon avis le cinquième bien
aussi mais bon on fait un tout cas c'est
bien pour faire connaître le jeu
d'échecs ou s'amusant sur ses bons
original d'avoir bon je sais pas ils
sont sages je crois ça joueurs chacun
dans sa maison en train de jouer le même
tournoi à quoi ces conneries je n'ai
qu'un arbitre par le col problème il est
là c'est que pour évidemment pour que
tout le monde ait les mêmes chances vaut
qu'un arbitre dans chaque maison voilà
dans chaque maison
alors là c'est ça c'est ça la difficulté
mais bon c'est très bien c'est très bien
il faudrait que
ça peut être un moyen de promotion en
tout cas c'est un moyen de promotion du
jeu d'échecs résultats actuels pour
l'instant donc kasparov et en finale
sans surprise il a battu la dame s'est
justement donc maintenant parler du
fameux michael en demi finale donc il
est en finale et en face la deuxième
demi-finale en contre et soisy de leurs
souhaits morose évident chez pika pika
dunkerque a fait un bon tournoi de wecan
dit je pense qu'il avait il un regain de
forme des matches compliqués ou un match
aussi pouvaient y avait une histoire
meilhan et longue histoire mais j'avais
fait un match contre lui à monaco en 96
oui un match où on avait fait huit nuls
mais c'était pas faute d'avoir essayé de
gagner parce que les parties était
acharnée quoi mais bon c c'est assez
rare mais enfonce le match était terminé
sur un résultat égal
donc tu es un joueur que tu connais bien
aussi si énorme il sera encore ajouté à
propos de piquette et des joueurs
landais c'est qu'ils ont une chance
extraordinaire c'est qu'il ya un grand
sponsor s'appelle 20 nostrum qui aide
beaucoup
ou qui est des jeux qui l'a arrêté je
pense que je dois mon à celle organisée
l'organisme l'organisateur du tournoi de
monaco il est beaucoup ces joueurs là
mais c'est pour ça les grands espaces et
la vaisselle coq qui est un autre
donc voilà un pour tous les joueurs
landais c'est vrai que joueur comme
piquette mais je crois que si tu étais
sa bête noire joël quand vous étiez plus
jeune
oui et
il a pu fait qu'au fond progrès c'est
peut-être un peu plus vite que je l
après parce qu'il avait les moyens de
progresser parce que c'est encore une
fois c'est un sport donc les échecs on a
eu des trajectoires assez similaire
similaire vous formulerez bon disons
qu'à un moment il était un peu derrière
puis dont il est revenu au niveau et on
en a toujours évolué un peu quand même
au niveau d'anglais seront alors
deuxième actualité de cette semaine la
sienne plus imbriquées celle ci c'est
l'actualité je dirais qu'ils se qui se
mélangent parce qu'on a le match adam
cyra one donc le numéro anglais michael
adams contre le numéro un américain
ferman c'est ça il est toujours numéro 1
américain fois ci ont aussi ont des
excuses comme ce qui est vrai oui
d'accord qui qui joue pendant ses
vacances
oui je pense que plus donc il ya ça sert
à roanne aux bermudes et ces deux
joueurs jouer le cas cependant grand
prix en même temps elle a recueilli
jouer leur parti ils font un match en 10
parties je prends et en même temps quand
donc entre les parties jouées sur le
internet
d'ailleurs avec des horaires sûrement
décalé par rapport aux autres comment
ils peuvent gérer ça moi j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient fait une partie nulle très
rapide
12 coup franc à la scène qui me rend
donc juste comme ça peut-être pour se
réserver pour le message je crois que
c'est une volonté effectivement de
kasparov de montrer que l'internet ne
permet finalement un joueur de jouer
plusieurs tournois en même temps il faut
reconnaître que kasparov fait toujours
attention c'est le seul joueur au monde
qui aujourd'hui fait parler d échec
autour de son nom donc ils en profitent
et c'est je suis persuadé que il a voulu
absolument que y ait des joueurs qui
participent à un autre tournoi on a vu
que l'on va c'est sûr que sportivement
c'est évidemment s'ils viennent l'un des
deux tournois en pâtit mais c'est
évident donc là certainement un choeur
dams alors ya eu un problème avec dix
juniors je sais pas s'il faut qu'on en
parle ça qu'il y avait un type d'homme
mais il y avait le petit frère de deeper
blue qui étaient inscrits dans le
tournoi kasparov qui a passé des tours
qui a battu qu'en matinée ska entre
autres et qui a été éliminée parce qu'il
ya eu un bug informatique ou une coupure
de courant bon voilà c'était évident que
si de deep sleep junior avait gagné
contre adams y jouer contre eux kasparov
et on sait que kasparov a du mal contre
les lip mon avis il n'a pas dû mal parce
qu'il est moins fort c'est parce que il
a justement il a une manière de jouer
très psychologique serre très fort
encore une fois ont même pas en cause
ses talents de joueur d'échecs
mais alors que contre une machine
c'était le psychologique sont beaucoup
moins importants banques beaucoup moins
donc en tout cas voilà donc est pudique
junior et kasparov est évidemment favori
dans son tournoi donc aura terminé donc
78 donc je crois que mike ryan semaine
de deux points
on doit rester deux ou trois parties
donc a priori y va il aime gagner le
match l'an passé on était c'est la
revanche du d'un match qui a vu l'homme
qui avait eu lieu l'an passé et l'an
passé serra one avait fait un bon
résultat puisqu'ils avaient fait nul
entre adams n'est pas favori évidemment
et cette année bombay va perdre ce qui
sera pas non plus quelque chose
d'étonnant alors oui tout à fait
souvenez vous réveille pas de match mais
on s'attend à tout sauf tombe décidément
très bien donc ce michael adams ont qui
va venir jouer ce grand prix de bordeaux
donc avait joué lautier et on s'attend à
voir
soit une très belle demi ou voir finale
entre les deux joueurs
on va voir ce qui se passe et donc on va
terminer ce tour d'actualité avec donc
la fille nature officiel de joël lautier
pour la venue au grand prix de bordeaux
je sais pas si la caméra pour montrer
leur de donc joël lautier voilà qui
confirme sa participation à ce trophée
ciel ces assurances donc c'est le
quatrième grand prix de bordeaux frappé
bien bertrand tu peux expliquer le
principe de ce tournoi qui avait diffusé
en direct sur diagonale les 6 et 7 avril
c'est un cetain
tournoi de parties rapides avec 4,4 très
fort grand maître il ya déjà eu dans ton
tournoi je crois shirov l'écho un winch
et enflé qu ils sont 4e et 5e jour lundi
au tpi match philman qui s'affrontent
sous forme d'élimination directe c'était
l'heure comme au tennis en deux sets
gagnants avec un tie break et c'est
retransmise sur écran géant et commenter
en direct par des joueurs par des
journalistes et par les grands maîtres
voilà donc c'est un vrai spectacle ce
sont les échecs spectacle avait été
initiée là aussi il ya de ça une dizaine
d'années au trophée limo par puis après
le trophée une telle et c'est tout à
fait bien que tu es repris le flambeau
et puis je crois que on en a déjà parlé
tu es en train de monter un circuit
donc il y aura en france en tout cas
pour commencer de trois tournois de ce
type et c'est vrai que c'est ça qui
attire le public encore une fois
pourquoi les parties rapides ou semi
rapide il ya des partis qui dure deux
fois 25 minutes donc 25 minutes de jeu
par joueur parce que ce sont des partis
qui où il ya déjà une certaine qualité
du jeu et ses soins des partis qui
peuvent être suivies par le public par
internet par la télé par les médias je
crois que même si c'est un type de trois
thèmes bien je t'avais dit une fois
justement que tu n'étais pour ce type ne
trouve qu'un a passé le tournoi comme ça
il deviendra beaucoup plus d'abord c'est
plus facile à organiser ça dure moins
longtemps fasciné mais bon disons que ça
dure ce week-end c'était facile que dans
dix jours je pensais plus facile de
faire venir des publics soit un tournoi
comme ça parce que le mont le constater
plus spectaculaire donc les gens
puissent on me dit d'aller voir ce qui
se passe et puis ensuite c'est aussi
plus facile à montrer à la télé où il ya
beaucoup d'atouts pour le joueur mais
pour les joueurs pour le joueur c'est
beaucoup plus de façons par contre c'est
plus difficile pour les nerfs
mais bon c'est comment on pensait aussi
comme un peu un amusement c'est il ya
quelque chose si on revoit on retrouve
un peu le l'envi de jouer aux échecs
vraiment d'ailleurs au sens propre du
terme et non pas juste faire son tour -
volée mais ces points et c'est vraiment
pour bon pour se faire un peu plaisir
aussi pour s'amuser
donc c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup
ce genre de tournoi et
et j'espère qu'il y aura beaucoup plus
et je me rappelle d'avoir vu thomas
trophée bompard quand on est battu
mauvaise passe qui oui et je crois qu'à
la fin du match et était sorti avec le
poing levé un petit peu comme un
tennisman à la fin non mais c'est vrai
que le taux d'adrénaline monte
dangereusement dans et dans l'est dans
les phases de fin de partie quoi donc
c'est assez normal qu'on rcc réaction là
mais bon c'est vrai ça serait un peu
bizarre dans une partie normale au bout
d'une longue finale gagnée en 90 coup
brillait pas du tout la même tension
c'est pas pareil mais je pense que c'est
bien de montrer que les échecs ça peut
être ça aussi c'est pas c'est pas
simplement c'est vrai que les échecs
c'est un jeu compliqué qu'on les
amateurs qui connaissent bien le jeu
apprécié et les stratégies bon feeling
et cetera les les longs calculs et c'est
vrai que quand on joue à un rythme plus
rapide la qualité en pâtit on ne peut
pas le nier mais ceci dit on s'est mises
+ peut-être et c'est bien donc rendez
vous 6 et 7 avril prochains à bordeaux
pour voir ce grand spectacle ou sur
internet évidemment puisque ça sera
diffusée en direct est donc disponible
en différé aussi sur diagonale ça sera
deuxième fois qu'on fait ce type
d'opération mère travail après le match
de bastia
oui vous avez bien suivi je crois qu'il
y avait dix mille internautes
oui à l'islam il a déjà cumulé qui
l'avait vu en direct et en différé donc
sa ceinture du monde
donc voilà on va passer maintenant la
partie du jour je vous rappelle que pour
suivre cette partie avec nous il s'agit
en l'occurrence de la partie bosse
beaucoup contre michael adams ou
kasparov grand prix justement sur
internet vous pouvez cliquer sur votre
droit sur l'icône jouer pour avoir
l'applet java qui permet de suivre la
partie
ou bien télécharger un logiciel dans la
partie différée de diagonale et lire le
fichier pgn en cliquant dessus tout
simplement voilà donc vous allez aussi
pouvoir suivre sur la vidéo évidemment
la partie avec les commentaires donc de
jouer le lotier bertrand guyard sur
cette partie voilà donc on va tout de
suite faire apparaître sur l'écran là
ces deux parties donc vos risques ou
rentrer
michael adams voilà donc en fait on a
commenté le premier coup peut-être
bertrand rapidement on peut les
commenter on va arriver tout de suite au
troisième coup avec le coude et noir le
courroux des 4 c'est une défense
ninkovic nadav et l'idée dé l'idée des
noix 6 et de clous et donc le cavalier
c3 afin d'amoindrir le contrôle des
blancs sur la case blanche
4 donc ici des noirs on va voir une
stratégie sur les premiers coup
d'essayer de se battre sur les cases
quatre des cinq sur les cases blanches 1
son cavalier donc on ne peut plus
évidemment contrôler ses 15 la mesure où
il est donc bloquée par un parent se
fout je pense que je ne le contredira
pas je suis maintenant c'est vrai que le
calibre ça fait donc on va rater un
petit peu avancé alors vous me dites
quand c'est que vous voulez donner des
commentaires sur son sur ses coûts 4e
coup trois écoutes de développement
aussi classique c'est pour sortir le
ventre bien stein ces noms que je jouais
beaucoup de fois en 50 parties le nombre
est donc en fait l'idée c'est simplement
de développer les pièces puisque en fait
l'idée principale et blanc tatoué sur
cette poussée de 4 finalement mais comme
c'est pas possible dans l'immédiat on va
on va d'abord développé les pièces
corfou des trois cas veille à 3 petit
rock et ensuite une fois que le clouage
ce n'est que là n'existe plus on va
peut-être songer la joueuse aux cadres
alors on va voir
effectivement comment se déroule donc
les blancs continuent de sortir leurs
pièces logiquement la noire vous ne
poussez central cc une possibilité je
crois qu'il ya d'autres coûts a noté à
ce moment là on peut pousser aussi
fiancée on peut faire c'est 5 mai c'est
le coût principal quand même dans cette
position donc là il ya pas grand chose a
commenté encore une fois on est dans la
théorie bertrand non mais on est très
bien cette position
voilà oui c'est peut-être qu'on pourra
demander à joël savoir si qqun cauet
adam sont des spécialistes de cette
variante sa ducati peut nous répondre
un homme se joue très souvent rimsevics
son ouverture principal sur des 4 quant
à gauche qu il a un style un peu plus
difficile à cerner puisqu'il joue pas
mal l'ouverture différentes mais c'est
quand même un produit de l'école
classique eux les échecs vous deviez tic
qui connaît une icône est bien sûr le
système donc la cia au 6e couleurs
peut-être un coup intéressant à noter
aller avec le coût 6 à 3 les blancs pose
la question aux fous puisque donc se
foutent attaqué un soldat il ya
plusieurs possibilités pour les noirs en
fait l'idée de jouer à trois si
rapidement c'est qu'on veut voir ce que
ce soit aussi voir la réaction des noirs
on veut se garder la possibilité de
sortir le canadien
ou f3 donc ce cavalier si c'est le cas
ce soit sur la 15e 2 soit sur la kf3
donc si les blancs si les noirs parce
qu'on prend dans ses 3
si on attend on aimerait bien jouer
cavalier ou deux par la suite pour
pourra faire f3 et le cas toujours cette
idée de pousser au centre d'accord donc
pousser l'idée c'est donc de pousser le
pion à ce 3 pour ensuite avoir la
poussée donc centrale
4 et pour ça il faut que ce fou se
décide à 10 ans soit assez chambre il
faudrait qu'il faut résoudre le problème
de cette loi est bon de savoir si on va
pouvoir jouer 4 ou pas et si le fou noir
se retire sur sur 7 par exemple à ce
moment là on aime on sort le caler dans
manon ex 3 et on change de stratégie
alors on va voir ce que choisit donc
michael adams il choisit finalement de
prendre de prendre le cavalier donc les
deux possibilités où était la deuxième
ou telle route et de mettre le fou sur
la case de 7
oui mais bon c'est dans cette position
particulière celle très peu joué parce
que c'est moins intéressant ça aurait
été intéressant de le faire si les
blancs et jouer cavalier
j'ai eu 2 ou le faire à trois dîners en
région et un coup et sur 1,3 de fer
fawcett pas ce qu'est ce qu'on a c'est
pas la peine au dmfu pour pourquoi liste
aussi entrepris par cas au lieu de bon
j'ai pas c'était un peu compliqué ce que
j'explique mes mais dans ce cas dans
cette position c'est normal de chefs ou
pour ces trois événements que ce coup là
d'accord donc libre en reprennent
évidemment le fou avec l'option b hélas
les noirs choisissent de libérer la
peut-être la tension au centre il choisi
d'échanger le pion ici sur la case de
ses cadres
moi je dirais c'est autrement je pense
que ici ils ont donné la paire de fou
donc c'est important échec
ils sont en revanche mieux développer
puisqu'ils ont déjà rockets il faut donc
qu'ils essaient d'ouvrir la position
pour profiter momentanément de leurs
avantages de développement on est ce
qu'on dit pas souvent que c'est la
position souvent c'est les fous qui sont
plus forts oui mais ici c'est la paire
de fou contre l'avant de développement
c'est le thème tous cas du début de
parures et je pense que c'est à peu près
ça effectivement
bon il ya quand même il ya des règles
comme tu l'as dit stéphane qui sont
écrites dans le marbre mais enfin il
faut pas toujours non plus se fier c'est
vrai que là c'est pour ça que je posais
la question pensent que senna ce cas
précis la base au développement est
importante il faut en profiter
sinon si les blancs ont la possibilité
de sortir de pièces tranquillement dans
des problèmes donc reprises au huitième
coup il va en parler bien en fous ces 4
hélas les noirs ça et qu'on commence
ce qui est important aussi pour déchets
qui ne comptera pas de centrale
et ben oui les blancs ont une majorité
au sein depuis ce qu'ils ont ils savent
où me contredise ntsiba mais là y'a rien
à contredire parce que c'est en train si
les noirs font rien ici deux spéciales
via les blancs ils ont une structure de
pions au centre c'est 3 des 4 3 qui est
terrible avec l'albert de fucile les 6
et noir ne font rien à des blancs vont
prendre l'aventage petit à petit donc il
faut absolument qu'ils essayent de faire
quelque chose pour profiter de leur
avance de développement donc ce coup
ce coup ci instaure une tension centrale
et est ce que les blancs pourraient
reprendre le pion ccnq tout de suite là
je pose la question
ce sera peut être parce que si on gagne
un pion d'abord c'est temporaire on
dénombre le récupère très facilement et
par contre le résultat ce sera quand on
aura une structure de pions complètement
détruite à la dame on aura les noirs
vont récupérer le pion c5 par damas cinq
très rapidement donc le coup sissili
blanc prône évidemment le coup ici là tu
joues alinghi que le coût d'un masque on
attaque déjà ses cinq essais 3 on va
récupérer tout de suite un pion très
probable c5 et ensuite les plans vont
rester avec la fête des sens étroit et
ce serait une faiblesse assez sérieuse
que ne compensera pas le père de fonds
voilà donc explication rapide pourquoi
les blancs ne peuvent pas prendre ce
pion donc les blancs continuent en
développement tant qu'il manque à la f3
et là on retrouve quand même le coup que
jouer le site est sur le coup ça c'est
intéressant l'ancien c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure même la
connaissance d ouverture est moins forte
que celle de jeunes normalement ici on
joue souvent des plans classique à base
de cahiers ces systèmes cc et l'a
visiblement damas 5
c'est un couple qui va gêner goal com
oui bah en fait l'idée c'est de
d'empêcher les blancs de retomber dans
la vente habituels en profitant du fait
que on a réussi à ouvrir
ils ont le sens un peu plus vite que
d'habitude avec et noir donc on en
profite nous présente les brandons par
ok et le fait d'attaquer le pion c3 si
par exemple les blancs on protège
normalement il faut b2 maintenant les
noirs qui lit blanc jouer le couffo en
b2 pour bilou tout à fait standard pour
protéger le pion à ce moment là le noir
foncé pan des quatre donc les normands
et prendre sur la case des 4 et grâce au
cloud rage sur le roi là où tu as une
belle flash ball et céline exactement
les blancs ne peuvent lui reprendre
confiance et donc ils s'engageaient de
proppants de pion à eux et il sait leur
donne une structure de pions beaucoup
moins stable que que ce qu'ils auraient
aimé avoir conquis leur père au real et
quand c'est avec ses deux pions ici
voilà sinon ça s'appelle des pions
pendant et dans ce cas-là bon la
situation des blancs c'est un petit peu
détériorée au centre parce que les plans
pendant occupe de l'espace mais ils sont
aussi assez fragile donc en fait c'est
un coup si je résume l'idée c'est un
coût qui instaure une menace
positionnelle en fait oui ça permet pas
gagné de pions mais ça permet de dire
attention s'ils doivent donner leur rien
qui peut sa position avant une victoire
se construit petit à petit on peut pas
gagner tout fini ta fait alors donc là
c'est pourquoi donc on est aurez donc la
possibilité on m'a dit la possibilité de
foin b2c pour ça donc gaulle cauchoise
il y met le kung fu ici sur cette case
des deux langues 10e coup il met donc ce
fou en défense du pian du cul en c3 mais
on en obstruant les attaques de la dame
sur le roi est ce qui peut lui permettre
maintenant de reprendre des casiers ici
adams pour moi donc s'il ya la dame sait
maintenant ce promener sur le cas des
quatre on pourrait finalement maintenant
ça y est reprendre dupuis ont scellé
dans gardé une structure de pian très
saine
ça c'est un rêve ça c'est un rêve ouais
donc mettre la dame ne va pas permettre
ça et là ça lui plaît pas au pape ait
fait ça donc là ils interviennent donc
il joue alors ça c'est même précède
qu'on dissout dans l'ouverture on dit en
général faut éviter de bouger
plusieurs fois la même pièce alors
l'idée en fait de cette petite manoeuvre
c'est que
10e round 7 c'est vrai qu'on a joué le
coup d'armé en échange les bains en juin
qufu des deux volants tout le problème
est de savoir si c'est un coup utile ou
pas en réalité le font à deux années
pour mieux placer con c'est un certain
est par contre il à l'avant maignan de
maintenant les bords n'ont plus la
possibilité je veux four b2 c est ce qu
ils veulent dans une perspective non sur
les cinq prochains coups c'est de
pousser les pions ces trois ans ces cas
depuis qu'on retire les enfants des
trois par exemple vous voyez donc il
polit 17 pouces et ceux qui ont donc en
avant l histoire vélos fous en d3 et
ensuite le un fou placé en b2 après ces
quatre de bien-être est fort puisqu'ils
contrôlent toute la grande diagonale
si les noirs n'ont pas de [ __ ] casse
toi pour pour l'opposer et et là ce
serait intéressant avec le foin des deux
ce plan est plus vraiment possible
donc finalement les noirs avec cette
manoeuvre ont forcé du mal à remettre
leurs fous sur la case des 2 alors que
logiquement ils auraient dû faire ça
aurait été mieux pour eux de le mettre
sur la case intervenants sens où on a
l'impression qu'ils ont perdu un temps
en fait non ils ont plus ou moins
inciter les bains joue un coût qui est
plutôt favorablement une subtilité
d'ouverture ans là bas ça c'est un jeu
on peut faire deux remarques générales
rapidement c'est que ces jeux modernes
c'est à dire qu'évidemment là on a quand
même deux de très fort grand maître qui
connaissent évidemment toutes ces
subtilités qui aujourd'hui c'est
finalement d'amener les
le joueur adverse sur des positions
qu'ils maîtrisent mois tout à fait donc
je crois qu'il est arrivé il nous faut
en voir les blancs jouent le coup
dessous des 3
tout simplement je compte y avait une
menace noir je redirai qui était de
prendre sur la case des 4 et ensuite la
dame aurait pu prendre le fou donc ils
ont remplacé leurs fouilles sur une case
- un peu plus safe quoi un peu plus
tranquille
voilà donc maintenant les noirs jouent
le coup aux et 11e coup le coude v6
alors simplement peut-être avec l'idée
simple ce que le fou ces huit ici est
bouché sur cette diagonale par le pion à
eux 6 donc ils veulent mettre le fou
soit sur la case bessette soit
éventuellement même sur la case as his
way
l'une de ces deux cases exactement où
nous leur a donc vous axez soit cette
diagonale ici qu'est la plus longue pour
ce fou soit celle ci qui pourrait
affaiblir la grée sentent surtout pour
affirmer s'il verra si c'est surtout
pour affaiblir la casse et 4 wikio
passagers se débarrasse de la paire de
fout des blancs skema n'a pas une
montagne à la bombe est simple les
échecs au fond c'est finalement
s'expliquer comme ça donc là alors là
les blancs font une action maintenant
ils n'auront pas encore ok on peut
douter ça peut-être parce que souvent on
dit aussi qu'il faut croquer lille on
épure ok essayer de roquet 1
mais là il joue tout de suite le coup
donc du pion aux trois sur la case ou
quatre noms qu'ils essaient de prendre
position au centre
oui mais en fait il avait une option ici
je pense qu'il n'a pas vraiment vu que
adam sous les phares fois ci ce qui est
le prochain coup qu'il a joué puisqu'il
aurait très bien pu jouer dan o'dowd
abord mais alors vous empêcher cette
possibilité et ensuite vous jouez au 4
qui condamne son épopée au grand jour je
reviens juste au coude avant la course à
regarder ça tout à l'heure voilà donc
pour une fois qu'on a préparé des partis
sur des modes de jeu peut-être vous vous
demandez ce qu'il en pense que c'est ce
que j'avais pensé en tout cas sur dame
deux équipes ouvrir 107 4 2 en
contrôlant doublement donc avec le fouet
la dame la casa 6 à ce moment là on
aurait pu faire flamber 7 mai sur quatre
donc le fou aurait pu venir on va y
aller doucement sur la case bessette
je sais pas si on peut le voir parce
qu'il ya place à coude et essayer de
contrôler cela de carterie mais là
j'avais vu ses quatre peut-être mais
c'est peut-être idiot non c'est vrai que
des poussées de tout simplement oui on
va simplement retiré le faut mais on
affirmer la tension sont entrés pendant
les longues années de guerre mondiale 17
départements ne souhaitait plus précis
l'été place à six rapports aussi donc
c'est peut-être une faute de pouce
boucau devant jouer son coup et 4 qui
permet finalement voir ça y est de jouer
là pouf oacis et là on peut noter que
donc le fou ici menace de s'échanger
contre le foot est roi et les blancs ont
pas tellement le choix parce que si
retirer leur fou serait catastrophique
ici ils pourraient plus rock et du toit
cloué au centre ça serait une ce serait
terrible dit très difficile à défendre
je pense que le public serait indigné
donc on voit tout de suite donc là les
blanches ont choisi finalement de forcer
les fans de d'échangés eux-mêmes donc ou
13e coup franc à six et noir reprennent
du cavaly ça c'est logique et maintenant
finalement ce fameux coup de deux mais
peut-être un peu tard d'après ce qu'on a
pu voir
oui bon on te sent il obligé de
maintenant deux attaques lecavalier à 6
protéger sentiers raquettes au passage
on oublie un peu vite attaqué et ça
compte sans contrôle ça protège depuis
en 4 donc un coup à w9 et y met m'enfin
ça va pas vraiment arrangé la situation
des bleus ont donc on va voir au coup
suivant des noirs donc coup suivant des
noirs voilà un petit coup d'un 17la qui
je protège le cavalier lecavalier à 6
c'est hugo est simple le pendant de
dameuses des blancs c'est qu'il protège
à 6 et irait attaque cas de nos voiles
alors ça c'est dans cette émission il ya
une attaque sur le pion à quatre avec
conjuguer avec le cavally et ce qui est
gênant pour les blancs c'est que comme
ils ont ils ont été un peu pris de
vitesse dans cette partie ils ont pas le
temps de rockets alors si on imagine
qu'il accusait qu'ils aient déjà ok avec
le bras en juin il pourrait jouer ici
tout est fait un protégé le pion sans
être obligé de bouger il ça veut dire
qu'elle garderait un ce qu'on appelle un
centre parfait c'est à dire qu'ils
appellent les deux mon gars toutes les
potentialités on peut pousser le champ
des poussées piano et là comme ils
peuvent
comme il peut pas le faire il l'objet de
pousser son pied en avant comme il l'a
fait dans la partie donc ils oublié ça
oblige les blancs à pour protéger ce
plan le pousser et
tu nous dis que cette structure ici de
pian et moins souple dans ce que c'est
mais c'était ça son espace et
inscriptions seront sur les deux cases à
côté ils peuvent pousser soit à droite
soit à gauche et là sa liaison fixe et
sally leur choix un coup avant les
blancs avaient un centre mobile
après ce coup on peut imaginer qu'il va
y avoir un échange de dépenser
prochainement c'est ton et 4 ces points
d'écart et blanc vont se retrouver avec
un pion des quatre arriérés sur une
colonne ouverte ce qui est le parent
mais c'est ce qu'on va voir c'était le
cauchemar du joueur du shakhtar alors
c'est peut-être son abord je tiens
c'était le thème de la partie là une
question une question générale donc là
tu penses que les noirs sont déjà un peu
mieux
ah oui c'est certain tu es certain
finances on peut mieux puisqu'ils ont un
objectif stratégique claire le pion des
quatre qui est faible
toutes les cases blanches qui sont
affaiblis maintenant notamment une
splendide cadre des 5e bon pour le
cavalier noir et
en fait ce que ceux qui ont des quatre
effet non seulement parce que il est
facile à attaquer mais en plus il est
complètement inopérant effet rien
n'était ou rien du tout ici alors que
chez les noirs les pions le pion en plus
elle dame lui va faire quelque chose il
va les pousser et est donc en puisant
quasiment un peu plus c'est de la
prescience parce que c'est ce qui se
passe on va on va voir effectivement
c'est à la passe donc là les noirs
choisissent de mettre leurs cavaliers
sur la case ou 4 alors est-ce que ce
cavalier peut menacer de s'échanger
contre le fou est ce que ça c'est bruce
est faussée possibilité c'est possible
enfin il va pas se presser de le faire
de toute façon puisque le fou peut pas
partir à cause du psion c3 qui parle à
attendre et aussitôt ce cadre une
attaque à la fois le fruit et le pardon
et le pion ces trois ans jusqu'à le
faire en rouge
voilà donc le fou ne peut pas bouger
sous peine de perdre ce fameux pions
donc bon enfin l'idée la raison pour
laquelle il a joué le client et 4 c'est
c'est une idée qui est connu aux déchets
textiles avait fait salle emile canu en
d5 à ce moment là l'autre cavaliers ici
aurait manqué de
deux cases intéressante puisque sa
trajectoire normale ici à partir
d'assister devenir ans et 7 et en d5 c7
et des cinq entités politiques oui oui
qui doit essayer de se recycler congrès
de tours donc essayé récit sept cars
avait donc été occupée par l'autre
cabinet il aurait été un peu embêté donc
c'est pour ça qu'il a préféré la garder
pour l'autre voilà donc c'est très
simple c'est limpide en fait donc on va
avoir été dans mon petit finalement ça y
est cette rampe tard pour les blancs du
riz les dix ans ils sont un peu moins
bien ça sur elham a 15 ans quand tu
disais effectivement ce fameux pions ici
ce fameux pions des quatre ici
maintenant ça y est tu commences à être
sous pression avec le pion c5 et la tour
des huit salles et qui commence à
instaurer une pression et on voit
qu'effectivement les blancs ont du mal à
le défendre
et si les changes si ce pion s'échanger
contre le pion de ces cinq ans verrez
que ce soit le pion c3 qui seraient tous
seuls sûrement est très difficile à
défendre
oui non ce serait ce serait très mauvais
pour les blondes et parce que l'autre
cavaliers ainsi entre tous pris dans le
jeu prenant ses seins que ce serait se
serait perdu
donc rien à dire de plus que ça non
alors voyons donc voyons la suite la
bourse ball kobe comment ça va être
aussi ses pièces en finalement de
position défensive puisqu'il met de la
tour ici en d1 avec l'idée que le fou
par exemple pourrait venir peut-être
sous cette case oui eux et contrôlée ici
le pion des quatre oui oui bon il peut
être une vague menace un peu optimiste
mais mais bon qui mérite d'être
soulignée il veut peut-être fou et
ensuite passer la tour en d3 et ensuite
faire tours et troyes et gagner le
cavalier qui serait enfermée carré plus
de 15 ans de retraite
il faut quand même faire attention ces
cavaliers au centre effectivement
pourrait être donc il a une petite idée
assez intéressante pas facile à réaliser
mais nos jours il faut faire attention
alors donc l'aller michael adams choisi
de
d'échanger une première fois donc ici au
17e coup donc 17e coup des noirs des
changes une première fois au centre donc
là les blancs reprennent du plan c est
maintenant ça y est choisi de libérer
son cavalier de ces menaces au cotton
citée dans sa coquille qui étaient les
premiers à devoir est un peu curieux
puisque le cavalier les malheurs bien et
le faux pas terrible par contre mais bon
les échecs sont pas que des concepts
abstraits c'est aussi des problèmes
concrets et le cavalier de 4 et quand
même le miracle malgré tout et c'est
assez facile d'attaquer par le pardonne
à manosque que j'ai que j'ai mentionnés
regarde là on peut faire une remarque
d'un signal c'est qu'on va voir on va
assister à une partie technique on
assister à quitter maintenant que pour
michael adams on peut dire que c'est une
partie technique
donc l'idée générale on va l'avoir
maintenant dans les coups suivants je
pense assez rapidement c'est que donc ce
ce pion pour les blancs ici des quatre
est hariri n'est pas défendue par action
de sa même couleur et il a beaucoup de
mal à avancer puisque les noirs contre
le port fait mans la caisse des 5 avec
la dame la tour et ce fameux aux
cavaliers via la casse et 7 va
s'installer sur cette case et ça va
complètement bloquée en fait les pions
noirs et par contre les noirs ont comme
lui citer jouer le tout à l'heure ici la
possibilité d'avoir deux pions contre un
seul pour les blancs donc tous les tout
ce qui est marqué dans mon système de
nîmes the beach non mais c'est vrai que
de contrôler le blocage du pur des
quatre sur la case de blocage des 5
alors on va voir les coûts suivante qui
répondent à cette ce plan générera du
coin donc les blancs prennent évidemment
le fou là les noirs vous d'abord le coup
à six c'est toujours un coup qu'on
on a envie de jouer c'est très important
c'est pas juste des considérations
générales
c'est parce que les blancs avaient quand
même une idée de contre jose s'est fait
de mettre un cavalier en d6 et donc
qu'il serait passé par la case g5 et
ensuite capté des six par le cas il
serait venu sur cette case ensuite par
la case 4 voilà et il sera arrivé
jusqu'en des sites il sera mis sur cette
superbe classe en fait sens et quelque
chose dans l'ensemble des trajets
d'emploi dames c'est madame c'est un
excellent joueur positionnelle ça veut
dire que non seulement il voit ses plans
à 8 mais il voit aussi les plans de
défense de l'adversaire à skis et ski
est très important d'accord donc c'est
l'idée de ce cookie aux échecs vous
s'occupe et atteindrait ce que fait
l'adversaire tout en se alors on va voir
donc maintenant les blancs ici d'activer
la dernière pièce qui ne joue pas cette
tour
si maintenant voilà qui sur une colonne
ouverte comme principaux signes général
c'est un principe général ça de kevin
pièce mais il est toujours attendre -
ces axes il avait pu repêcher qui a
laissé cette alors on va voir tout de
suite voilà les noyés jack ou tient
effectivement maintenant les normes
mètres localisée sur la casse et c'est
tu disais le bertrand la menace des
blancs sont arrêtées de jouer la
deuxième tour sur cette case hélas le
coup le cavaliere aurait été dans
l'impossibilité d'aller sur rhône à sète
mais là maintenant c'est maintenant
c'est plus possible donc maintenant
réglant le fond mais trop tard donc au
25e coup autour des 1 c2 donc là
évidemment la menace c'est de prendre le
cavalier c7 est là tout de suite les
noirs maintenant c'est lié aux comptes
créés tease leurs plans ça y est ils ont
une superbe cavaliers ici passer sous
cette case qui contrôlent beaucoup de
cases et puis fixe complètement
c'est une gloire ici qui sont dans
l'immobilité parfaite en fait maintenant
les blancs ont quand même toujours le
même plan à leur disposition il pourrait
essayer de faire qu'elle était 2,4 et
2,6 puisqu'ils peuvent plus passer par
2,5 à risque de passer par 2 2 le 4 et
des fils alors le problème c'est que là
il ya une réfutation tactique
immédiatement s'il veut qu avait des
deux c'est kaka vdv 4 qui attaquent la
dame d'oé menace m'attend j'ai de parler
d'amendés 7 alors qu'on va peut-être
montrer voilà très rapidement je vais
enlever les flèches gmail il ya beaucoup
de flèche alors on veut juste montrer
séduisante parce que celle-ci
intéressant donc une idée des blancs
auraient pu être donc de jouer ce
cavalier ici sur la place des deux pour
aller sur la case de 4 et ensuite sur la
case des six mais dans ce cas là je vous
dis que le couple cavalier f4 attaque la
dame et attaque la casse g2 avec la dame
ici qui menacent donc peau mate
voilà c'est ça et là que fait beaucoup
d'élèves saurez vous serez forcé le gain
d'un pion puisque les blancs auraient pu
parer le match mais il aurait perdu le
plan des quatre ans l'opération c'est
pour ça que vous le courage ou un jour
j'ai trouvé ici donc la goule coujoux g3
donc ils empêchent tout simplement de le
câble et noir devenir ce cette case
donc là les noirs maintenant active là
encore une fois leur dernière pièce qui
ne jouait pas l'atout de la tour ici et
propose un échange ici d'un échange de
tout en fait oui non ce qui est assez
remarquable dans cette partie et dans le
style d'adams en général c'est que tout
est extrêmement simple et
français c'est bon mais irréprochable
dans cette position le seul contre joe
des blancs donc c'est que comme
j'expliquais de m le kenyan des 6 et se
rencontrent jeu intéressant s'il peut
garder les deux tours parce qu'elles
sont là la dame noire manque un peu de
cases les tourments tuellement arrivée
ans et six peuvent créer des problèmes
donc lui doit simplement échanger les
pièces de ce qu'ils arrivent tout est
changé c'est à dire les deux tours et la
dame
la finale est difficile pour les blancs
parce que le ghana peut pas s'éloigner
voilà ce fameux pions ici ses deux pions
ici qui sont qui permet de pousser
contre un seul pion pour les blancs donc
c'est les noirs peuvent crimes qui ont
passé deux côtés davantage noir est
tellement important que tous les
échanges dans ce sens favorable et
bonbonnes c'est évidemment le voit tout
de suite et c'est pour ça qu'il
commencerait changer de caisse
alors on va on va accélérer les coûts
maintenant pour voir la réalisation de
ce plan par un paramètre que la dame si
on va arriver à la position critique de
la partie je crois bertrand alors s'il
te qui s'aiment beaucoup plus et on va
donc on va dérouler ses coûts maintenant
donc donc là les échanges de tours ce
fonds va s'allier ici là les noirs
commencent au 24e coup à accélérer leurs
créations de plus ont passé pendant
visible celle de pions en train donc on
va voir comment ça se déroule alors on
va dérouler parce que ça devienne
technique un petit peu on va pas pouvoir
complètement mais les coûts c'est en
revanche sur les cinq sens on peut faire
un commentaire d'un génial c'est à ce
qu'a dit tout à l'heure je elle c'est à
dire que les noirs se retrouve avec un
point de plus virtuellement à les dames
tout simplement assez plus virtuellement
maintenant puisque ça dit c'est bientôt
possible parce que ça nous rende plus
que la wii c'est leur seul moyen mais il
se raconte et voilà bâtiment mais allez
le damier bien plus en plus voilà voilà
il n'ya plus au passé donc cela menace
des noirs c'est tout simplement poussé
ce prix seulement que les blancs empêche
ce qui me pousse et ça ça valait bloqué
pour faire autre chose oui mais comme ce
sont des parties rapides
je pense que le mois on manque un peu de
précision quelque part un moment
puisqu'on va le voir
bon jusque jusqu'à dans quelques coups
les blancs pouvaient tenir la position
voilà n'en attend rien voilà si on
critique qui sent la position critique
au 36e coup là je l'aimais en fait
michael tu en intentant un piège pardon
de très très amusant dans lequel joue le
coup est tombé mais l'idée au départ
c'est de faire simplement à 5 1 se
prépare à pousser les pions donc l'idée
pour les noirs ce qu'on me dit jouer
c'est effectivement de pousser ses pions
et deux vers la dame tout simplement et
le coup de boule coup à dire tellement
évident on bloque le pian on paie son
attaque ça paraît vraiment exactement en
tentant de le faire donc la comco choisi
de jouer tour 1,5 et c'est effectivement
ça bloque nature en l1 avant de voir
comment est ce qu'il a perdu ensuite je
dois simplement dire que à la place de
faire torah 5 il aurait dû jouer damas
de ici dans cette position donc la dame
ici sur la case à 2 parce que ça empêche
la combinaison qui va suivre parce que
ça contrôler la seconde angers
importance et d'un contrôle la seconde
rangée et contrôler la guerre us contre
l'a45 avec la deuxième idée de damas vie
donc bon gars de position tenable alors
là donc que la goutte coton d'un petit
peu d'amiante dans le piège de michael
adams y jouent tour à cinq qui bloque
effectivement ce pion à 6 mai alors vous
notez qu'il ya toute une batterie de
laisser une combinaison assez inattendu
parce que le matériel est quand même
réduit pas à temps parce qu'une attaque
de match d'un seul coup c'est nul pas
parce qu'il faut voir c'est que la dame
1,8 ici contrôler une diagonale qui va
jusqu'au roi blanc
donc ils clouent entre autres ce
cavalier 3skey très joli c'est le
passage un peu la fin de la relève de la
garde à la dame qui ce qui s'efface
derrière la tour pour la laisser entrer
et c'est au monde jolie combinaison
voilà c'est donc sous coûtera 800 qudama
8 pardon en libère effectivement la tour
qui peuvent venir jusqu'à la case des
deux aussi qui est pas loin de pouvoir
faire un échec oran est donc là bon là
c'est la magie des jeux d échecs de rang
c'est la petite combinaison c'est ce que
ken block appelée la petite confidence
et une domination oppositionnel
sonné ça craque c'est vrai je l'a
expliqué qu'il y avait certainement des
moyens de tenir cette position alors tu
pense quand même que malgré tout cela a
été difficile
noir sont mieux c'est clair mais mais
c'est un gagnant encore travailler il
faut travailler
et là évidemment on a ça craque alors ça
craque alors on va voir tout de suite
pourquoi
37e coup pour ma que la dame se voir un
cavalier sur l'a43 ça c'est l'échec
échec au roi
c'est important échec ses échecs et ça
fait quand même une superbe fourchette
une fourchette familiale une fourchette
c'était accès attaque le roi et la dame
donc qui a qu'une seule possibilité si
les gens veulent pas perdre à partir ses
deux ponts de cavaliers il faut prendre
un cavalier ou alors on perd la dame
vinolas et après la prise du cavalier
baignoire assène le coup 38 alain
tourbez 2 saïda pour sautiller la tour
sur la septième rangée face sur la
seconde puisque c'est celle chez de
large et marqué en rouge pour les noirs
voilà ce qui fait échec
voilà et ils on peut noter c'est que le
bel et le roi va être obligée et laurent
blanc de partir de ce soir sur une case
où il va monter là mais ça va mais la
voilà ce qui va se passer après si tout
de suite après ces cas dame prend le
cavalier est ce que vous ayez un réseau
de manwin le matin parce qu'il a
abandonné visiblement la diva terrain
donc petite étude à voir après ce tour b
deux échecs en voir comment le matin
d'enseignants qui chante jean pierre
mercier l'avait
publiés dans libé c'est 1 2 1 2 1 2
étoiles ça la chronique de jean pierre
mercier
voilà une très jolie partie
positionnelle en fait de michael adams
donc il a bien brûlé le savons a
d'ailleurs typique de son style et il
n'ya bien comme on dit vi et son
adversaire oui c'est fait de petites
touches à droite et à gauche mais on
n'oublie jamais l'essentiel c'est ici
c'était la case des cinq échanges et une
paire de taux au bon moment et ensuite
mettre en un seul la majorité de l'aide
voilà donc après cette partie commenté
donc par bertrand guyard et joël lautier
on va passer à notre rubrique de josé
puisque je vous ai là ce soir donc il va
un petit peu mieux loti
oh
alors chers internautes bonsoir donc
aujourd'hui je suis de retour parmi vous
avec une joie et aujourd'hui j'ai bas
l'interview fantastique avec un joueur
un champion il est très brillant
d'emballage je reçois joël lautier
donc bon soir je réellement san jose
donc vu question est posée quand tu
étais plus jeune tu rêvais les champions
du monde
tu l'as été puisque tu as été champion
du monde juniors et maintenant est-ce
que tu l'ambitionne encore oui
absolument
jeudi sommes toujours d'être champion du
monde mais bon c'est quelque chose
disons que j'avais tendance à dire plus
facilement avant maintenant je pense
qu'il faut c'est surtout les résultats
qui doivent parler donc bon j'attends un
petit peu mais c'est quelque chose que
qui est très important pour moi donc
malgré tout et victoire de kasparov
s'est aussi battue et karpov
récemment il vend le choc tu as encore
le désir
mais quel est le moteur au fait cette
ambition c'est devenir champion du monde
en fait c'est de devenir bon maintenant
champion du monde c'est une appellation
un peu un peu particulière puisque la
formule a complètement changé
c'est devenu beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
une question de chance on peut le dire
devenir champion du monde c'est possible
même pour un grand maître qui est dans
les jeux c'est pas dans les 50 meilleurs
joueurs du monde comme kalichman
les devenu donc d'un coup d'un côté
c'est bien puisque c'est devenu
peut-être un peu plus facile
d'un autre côté je pense que ce qui est
vraiment important c'est sûr faire
partie des cinq meilleurs joueurs du
monde au classement elo ça c'est la
vraie preuve donc ton ambition est
intacte à dix on met d'ailleurs aussi
quand tu étais plus jeune tu étais un
peu plus disons listant par rapport aux
autres mots plus hostile et l'on dirait
que tu es plus ouvert plus apaisée
est-ce que ça ça un incident sauteuse
je sais pas moi je pense qu'on évolue
naturellement c'est tout c'est normal
quand on est un adolescent on est plus
seront peut-être un peu plus au sérieux
on a plus
je ne sais pas en bon c'est on a une
personnalité qui est pas tout à fait
développer encore peut-être enfin bon il
ya plein de raisons comme ça mais c'est
je pense non je pense pas que ce soit
vraiment ça aille de pair avec un
changement au niveau de jeu c'est des
choses différentes mais quand donc
j'aimerais seulement tu vas commencer la
joueuse d'échecs jeunes et comment tu
progresser est ce que tu as connu des
saints il ya un moment où tu t'es dit
non j'y arriverai plus où c'était une
évolution constante progressive petit à
petit en fait non le problème c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a atteint un certain
niveau pour aller plus loin
à chaque étape est extrêmement difficile
c'est le bon le problème que rencontrent
tous les joueurs de mon niveau à peu
près parce que bon on a pas vraiment de
gens qui puisse vous dire là il faut que
tu fasses ça que tu travailles de telle
façon on est vraiment livré sans même
puisque les autres joueurs ne sont pas
plus forts donc ne sont pas forcément
des conseillers très très pertinent à
donner et donc toute cette partie c'est
vraiment un travail de recherche avancée
de l'apprentissage lassé de la recherche
il faut trouver les nouvelles
informations soi-même et trouver ce qui
est vraiment la valeur ce qui est
intéressant et ça c'est un travail
difficile donc full monty anticipe me
prochaine question comment fais-tu
disons comment est ce que tu recherches
des défauts tu essayes de l'est de
trouver pour les démasquer pour les
prêter disons oui non mais les défauts
je veux ça fait longtemps que j'ai
trouvé le problème c'est qu'ils sont
toujours là
salam la difficulté c'est de s'en
débarrasser est bon de de les voir quand
on arrive à être assez critique avec soi
même de regarder quand même les
problèmes l'horizon on est trop mai
mais ensuite pour s'en débarrasser c'est
extrêmement difficile et d'un côté c'est
pas mal d'avoir un entraîneur
mais je pense que ce qui est décisif
c'est le travail
ce travail de recherche dont je parle
quand il faut faire soi même trouvé
vraiment le ce qui manque
voir un peu comment ça fonctionne chez
les autres bon c'est ce travail là mais
concrètement comment comment fais-tu
parce que tout à l'heure tu parlais de
galfingue qui était un peu trop bête
noire et uv dit une phrase tu as dis ça
c'est de la psychologie faut encore que
je travaille mais comment vas tu faire
certes tu vas prendre une position et tu
veux te dire tiens là je sais que je
craque c'est à ce moment là c'est non ce
serait assez déprimant si c'est que je
me vois que je passe en revue tous les
mots j'ai craqué non je pense que bon la
préparation psychologique c'est quelque
chose qui est plus vraiment du domaine
des échecs là c'est un peu différent
bon ça s'apparente un peu à la
psychologie sportive je pense que les
joueurs les sportifs qui sont qui sont
dans les sports individuels connaît ça
très bien un adversaire difficile des
situations de tournoi un peu tendu où on
joue pour le gain ou au contraire il
faut pas qu'on soit éliminé et c'est
donc là c'est un bon entre avec un peu
différent mais
je me concentre surtout quand même sur
le travail chic et inquiets le je pense
que qui est l'essentiel de c'est là que
peut faire la différence et tu tu
préfère travailler seul ou avec des gens
parce que les gens mais qui tue à
travailler tu as travaillé que ça de
l'air je pensais que très bobo aussi
sont devenus très fort finalement attend
potec donc nous avons un entraîneur et
toi est ce que quelqu'un t'a aidée dans
sa carrière de joueur oui oui bien sûr
il ya des joueurs qui montent ils m'ont
beaucoup aidé je pense notamment à mes
premiers entraîneurs une fois que je
suis devenu grand mail parce que j'en ai
vu d'autres avant mai
j'ai eu dit encore élève polonaise qui
sont des joueurs mon lev paul gay ce qui
malheureusement est décédé mais c'était
c'est un jour exceptionnel
je pense qu'il avait un style très pur
une approche scientifique du jeu et je
pense que c'est une approche quand même
qu'ils qui la bonne on a chacun cette
personnalité on peut pas tout ce travail
de la même façon mais c'est quelque
chose qui a en tout cas été me convenait
tout à fait c'est quelque chose que
j'essaie de continuer et quand ça tu
parlais de la fpf qui se voit la saison
sera encore chez nike est ce qui
concerne encore choisir je sais pas s'il
est si la russie aime transmettre
quelque chose dans mon jeu je ne suis
pas sûr mais
enfin ce que je trouve fabuleux c'est
c'est sa volonté de se battre
constamment
enfin bon c'est un monument des échecs
au but encore shaun hill à la presse que
70 ans il fait encore partie des 25 30
meilleurs joueurs du monde
et donc c'est un exemple pour tous les
joueurs et des gens avec qui tu aurais
aimé travailler tu n'as pas pu mais
parce que tu as aimé travailler karpov
ou même castor peut-être ce qui provoqua
sport j'ai pas besoin d'être avec lui ce
que je le bats déjà fatah comme tanné
des chemises rouges n'ont lésiné pas que
j'étais un grand fan du jeu car pau
c'est vrai je trouvais qu'il avait
quelque chose plus que les autres bons
que j'ai essayé de travailler avec lui
me vont ces conditions était un peu un
peu trop élevé pompe pour moi donc ça ne
s'est pas fait quoi mais c'est quelque
chose que j'aurais aimé faire donc en
fait si tu parle bien sûr de conditions
financières et qu'on plus jeune tu as eu
un sponsor et quitte à un kit a beaucoup
aidés est ce que maintenant finalement
il tend faudrait pas un autre pour pour
trouver des partenaires pour trouver des
oui bien sûr je pense que ce qui est je
pense qu est ce qui l avantage de
certains joueurs notamment kasparov
c'est qu'ils ont
vraiment une dire parce qu'une arme et
enfin ils ont une brigade on va dire de
deux secondes en d'entraîneur
d'assistants et ça c'est quand même une
ça fait une grosse différence sur sur
une somme de travail de plusieurs années
là-haut mois en travaillant pendant dix
heures j'arrive un bon un certain volume
de travail et lui il arrive à dix fois
plus bon déjà parce que c'est un
travailleur acharné lui-même mais en
plus il a il a des c des processeurs qui
travaillent en parallèle on peut dire il
va sont même entraînés à chacun robe
d'un côté il a nourri de quoi yann de
l'autre et m'ont peut-être d'autres
qu'on connaît pas donc
donc c'est difficile de lutter seul
contre contre un groupe de joueurs donc
bien sûr aussi si j'avais la possibilité
de ne serait-ce que d'avoir un
entraîneur régulier ce serait se serait
ce serait très bien mais on va conclure
là dessus mais chers internautes si vous
êtes milliardaire et vous pouvez d une
star mondiale des échecs
voilà je vous remercie change va autant
voir et puis au revoir je vais le pitch
on
oh
voilà c'est trop cool de josé donc on a
appris beaucoup
bertrand surjouée l'outil oui enfin il
n'a pas tout dit mais la diva balkans et
chaque pas chaque fois qu'on pose la
question comme ça des meilleurs joueurs
du monde j'avais posé parfois des
questions je me souviens à carpeaux fier
de ça quelques années ils disent mais
ils disent pas tout c'est normal quand
on a dans ses passes et passé par auch
mais c'est sûr que c'est sûr qu'il ya de
la technique de travail la technique
d'entraînement c'est quelque chose de
nos fonds d' assez secret et
ils peuvent pas tout dit alors oui mais
non mais c'est normal et je jouais il
faut qu'ils gardent des cartouches
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'ils
battent après contre les autres qui est
aussi stocks des secrets dans leur coin
bon alors la semaine prochaine qu'est ce
qui va se passer en fait de l'actualité
je crois que c'est sur cannes
en fait mme bertrand que ça va se passer
alors à cannes il ya le festival des
jeux de l'esprit n'a pendant une dizaine
de jours
c'est quand même ses côtés un grand
événement ça fait je crois 15 ans que ça
existe maintenant et il ya vous aurez
tous les jeux je crois qu'on peut parler
aussi de nos cousins de temps en temps
aussi bien je te colle jeu dames le jeu
de backgammon
il ya des tournois d'organiser des
exhibitions des grands maîtres dans
toutes les disciplines qui viennent
comme ça montrer leur art et puis il y
aura un événement effectivement un
soutien puisque rats non karpov n'a pas
aussi enfin champion du monde pendant x
années
et puis aujourd'hui je dirais champion
du monde vit champions en france et plus
exactement s'il aime enfin c'est
toujours un quand même un grand joueur
et puis contre etienne bacrot qui est
je tirais le nouveau lautier puisque j'y
allais l'a donc puisque aujourd'hui la
17 ans il a presque 2600 points elo 2595
1594 et là il fait un match exhibition
c'est un match exhibition assez
important de dire contre karpov à trois
canaux différents dans deux partis
sérieux je vais accélérer deux parties
semi-rapides aux rapides à 25 minutes et
deux parties blitz bon ben on souhaitons
lui bonne chance c'est vrai que faut
qu'il faut qu'ils essayent de faire un
bon résultat contre eux alors et à côté
aussi un open par élimination où jouent
et loire hollande
alors oui bah ça ça c'est notre vie
c'est notre chouchou ouais c'est le
chouchou des c je crois que s'il ya
laurent frayssinet et van cleef quatre
chefs
voilà qui joue à quatre chefs et fait
partie du club de cannes donc c'est lui
c'est le choc d'avenir du bassidj qui
est le grand mentor de temps on va on va
terminer rapidement je crois je vois
l'eau s'il ya quelque chose qui te
concerne aussi à cannes puisque il ya la
remise des feelies d'ordre de la
fédération c'est à dire l'élection des
meilleurs joueurs une somme concernée
par cette évidence cette élection que
les nominés dans les trois nominés oui
pourquoi tu sais c'est pas ça pas une
importance extraordinaire ccd
c'est des diplômes concerne enfin je
pense pas que dix ans les sportifs aient
besoin de ce land de communes de
reconnaissance qui compte et performance
ce que pensent les journalistes alors
dans les résultats c'est une chose mais
il faut quand même regarder les
résultats avant tout en tout cas ce que
pensent les journalistes c'est important
c'est con mais c'est vrai que depuis des
années j'ai une petite idée c'est que il
le donne toujours à etienne parce que
les plus jeunes
voilà donc en retard il a donc cette
émission spéciale donc avec joie les
outils du mot en français donc il sera à
bordeaux les 6 et 7 avril prochains
des rendez vous donc la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle émission
diagonale